i would say out of all the things that
i'm expert in i think the number one
thing is
in fatigue
that's definitely a certification that
you can't get from any university you
have to get it from the school of hard
knocks
but i personally have been so tired for
so many years and then overcame that
fatigue and then helped tens of
thousands of people
so i'm going to tell you right now i am
going to show you how to get your energy
back
i was doing all the wrong things i was
trying to take all these pills and
vitamins but there was something else
underneath my fatigue that i was missing
and until years later when i finally
figured it out it was like i took a
helmet off my head and i finally woke up
so let's talk about the seven reasons
why
you're tired the first reason is adrenal
fatigue
you have too much cortisol
what's interesting about cortisol
it's a stress hormone that adapts your
body to stress and under stress
your body switches to
running on glucose despite what your
diet is if you have too much stress your
body is going to basically run on
glucose this is why there's another name
for cortisol
glucocorticoid okay it's a
glucocorticoid it's a glucose type
hormone
meant for short-term energy it's
supposed to give you energy
but it ends up making you tired because
it's going to mobilize a lot of glucose
that's stored in your liver and it's
also going to make glucose out of
protein and fat that's called
gluconeogenesis
so here you are having all this glucose
flowing through your bloodstream and
then your blood sugar is going to
increase and then insulin is going to
come in there and push it down so when
you go through chronic stress that's
when things start to go downhill and all
that glucose will just make you
thoroughly exhausted all right so the
more stress you have
the more your body runs on sugar now
there's a little gland in the brain
called
amygdala and it's very similar to the
adrenal glands on top of the kidney
but it works on your brain in other
words it addresses
a certain type of stress
in your brain and that specific stress
is a fear
type stress it's a fear response
so amygdala has everything to do with
different shades of fear
whether it's a very high level fear like
you're shy
to a major
panic attack or you're terrified
or right in the middle you have anxiety
or you have worry
all those are fear states
and so anytime you have a fear state the
amygdala is involved and it's going to
affect a lot of different
biological processes like your ability
to sleep
like your ability to get into a calm
state and anything that's related to
fear is going to get you to avoid that
fear you probably heard of the saying um
you must face your fears right well when
you face your fears they no longer are
fierce because fear is about avoiding
something and as soon as you don't avoid
it and you face it
you don't have it anymore but the best
remedies
for an adrenal stress situation
or an overactive amygdala would be to
take
vitamin b1 okay good amounts of b1 in
the form of nutritional yeast that is
going to make you feel very calm now
some other things you can do is take
ashwagandha i have some more information
on that in a link down below but
ashwagandha is an adapted gym it
increases your tolerance to stress
there's many other herbs that are
adaptogens but ashwagandha is one of the
top herbs and then we have sleep more
sleep better control over your stress
better adrenal function and i will get
to sleep in a second
but the last thing i want to mention is
physical work
that's a very great therapy for stress
like any physical work that you can
start doing
it will really help you release that
stress now exercise is okay
but physical work is a lot better
because physical work and also exercise
helps to deplete that stress energy that
tends to build up that prevents you from
sleeping all right number two
sleep okay poor sleep will make you
tired and many times you can't sleep
because you have high cortisol because
you're stressed especially if it's
between 12 midnight and 2 o'clock in the
middle of the night that is when you're
supposed to have the lowest amount of
cortisol but
if your adrenals are overactive that's
the time that you're most awake and i
had a problem with that for years
until i figure things out now
one thing about sleep there's a sleep
hormone called melatonin i recently did
a very interesting video on melatonin
because there's two types of melatonin
there is one type that's in your
bloodstream and in the pineal gland but
there's another type of melatonin that
is in all of the your cells it's deep in
the cells it's called a subcellular
melatonin and the way that you increase
that melatonin is through infrared did
you realize that over 50 of the sun rays
are infrared
so that infrared is actually increasing
melatonin in all of your body's cells
which will greatly help your sleep
but another purpose of melatonin is to
act as a powerful antioxidant even more
powerful than glutathione in your liver
and so melatonin is really important in
countering
all the stress that we experience
and preventing a lot of oxidative damage
and free radical damage and so if you
can get out in the sun
definitely do that for a good period of
time
but if it's winter and you can't do that
you can also get infrared from a
fireplace or a campfire
or some candles
or red light therapy
but the sensation of infrared
is like the heat that you feel from the
sun
or from a fire or from a light
like incandescent light i'm not talking
about the
artificial lights that they have now
like from your computer and your cell
phone which will all counter the
infrared uh wavelength and deplete your
melatonin so that's probably one of the
reasons why people have a hard time
sleeping is they're sitting in front of
the computer all day long and they can't
seem to recharge the melatonin now the
other thing i'm going to recommend for
sleep which is a really great protocol
which i use on my body is i take
four of my sleep aid okay right before
bed about 20 minutes and three of my d3
and k2
that seems to work very effectively to
get into a really nice deep delta wave
sleep and it's allowed me to get like
even up to nine hours of sleep so i will
use that when i need to sleep a little
bit longer
but presently my sleep cycles are in
pretty good shape vitamin d3 helps to
reset the sleep centers it's great for
jet lag and it's very very important in
sleep cycles and so taking vitamin d
right before you go to bed is actually
going to help you sleep it's not going
to wake you up all right number three
post viral syndrome okay
so let's just say you just had coped or
some type of viral flu and now you have
this residual fatigue you have chronic
fatigue syndrome now the medical term
for this it's called myalgic and
cephalomyelitis now what does that mean
that's a fancy term for you have
a combination of muscle pain and
inflammation and soreness with
inflammation of your brain causing
cognitive deficits as well as fatigue
now that medical condition
mimics
the symptoms
of a b1 deficiency as well as a b3
deficiency so really what i think is
going on is you have this
inflammatory immune response
and it's creating massive oxidation
massive free radical damage
and you're going into this infection
with an already empty bucket of b
vitamins and the residual fatigue that
you have from this infection is really a
vitamin deficiency that's what it is
primarily vitamin b1
but also the other b vitamins as well as
other nutrients as well and so if you
just had an infection
and you start taking nutritional yeast
and or b1 try to find a natural source
and you also took
vitamin d3
with zinc
okay you're going to start to have more
energy there's some other things that
you can take too as powerful
antioxidants like nac
and
not taking a melatonin but being exposed
to the infrared which naturally
increases melatonin which i already
mentioned is a very powerful antioxidant
probably even more powerful
than glutathione now the other point i
want to bring up about viruses
is that when you have
existing viruses that are dormant in
your body they're called latent viruses
okay so you had an infection let's say
in high school like epstein-barr virus
and then 20 years later it comes out of
remission
it usually comes out of remission when
you experience stress because
cortisol
is an immune
suppressive
hormone
so it actually lowers your immune system
this is why a lot of people are on
prednisone for all sorts of infections
because it gets because it gets rid of
the symptoms but what it's really doing
it's wiping out the inflammation but
it's also wiping out the entire immune
response
so when you have high levels of cortisol
your immune system temporarily goes to
sleep
and the door opens up for these viruses
to come out and kick you when you're
down
so
if you have any type of post-viral
symptoms whether it's fatigue or
whatever
do whatever you can to find the cause of
your stress
and try to get rid of it because
it's going to be really hard to get rid
of that fatigue if you still have the
stress situation that's unresolved and
unfortunately
losses can be a part of that as well
it's called bereavement when you go
through losses the cortisol increases
the stress increases and the viruses can
come out and create all sorts of
problems as well so in that case if you
have that situation definitely follow
the things that i'm talking about
getting more sleep getting more
nutrition getting ir
taking certain nutrients et cetera all
right
another uh cause of fatigue
is having lyme
lyme disease and that comes from
a spirochite which is a type of bacteria
that can go in your body and create an
immune reaction
all the symptoms from lyme are actually
coming from your own
immune system trying to kill off
this microbe but it can't find it so
i recommend doing a natural type
antibiotic and that would be something
like oregano
garlic
thyme
sage
things that are natural that can help
boost your immune system but without the
side effects number five
insulin resistance okay if you're in a
high carb diet realize that your brain
is going to be slightly more unconscious
because that's what carbs do they make
your brain go to sleep so you're going
to definitely need a nap after you eat
when you go on a low carb diet
it actually wakes up your brain you
actually become more conscious you are
running your brain on ketones which is a
preferred fuel and so if you haven't
already
gone on a ketogenic diet within a minute
of fasting that could create the biggest
effect on your energy more than anything
and i did put a link down below for
those of you that are new to that topic
all right number six
low stomach acids if you don't have
stomach acid um especially if you as you
get older and you lose the acidity in
your stomach you're not going to be able
to absorb b12 you're not going to be
able to absorb iron too well both of
those conditions can cause anemia you're
not going to be able to break down
protein too well that can cause fatigue
you're going to be more susceptible to
getting sibo small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth that can make you tired not
to mention all the digestive problems
that you're going to have
those can make you tired as well and the
simple remedy is a combination of apple
cider vinegar and betaine hydrochloride
but just realize that
you need to take a lot of it in the
beginning you may need to take five to
six to seven tablets right before you
eat
for
some weeks
before you really start to turn things
around because betaine hydrochloride is
not a very concentrated amount of
hydrochloric acid it's a very weak
type of acid that takes wild to build up
all right and the last point i'm going
to bring up is
vitamin deficiencies that can create
fatigue it's not as common
but it can create fatigue and i just
mentioned the b12 i just mentioned the
iron but i didn't mention potassium
in all of your cells you have a sodium
potassium pump
that generates electrical energy for
your cells so
you need a lot of potassium to generate
that energy it's very easy to get sodium
but it's more difficult to get potassium
and the way you get that is through
large amounts of
salads that's right that can give you a
lot of energy so that's something if you
haven't done before you might want to
start increasing more salad to increase
more potassium as well as the next
mineral which is also
involved in energy and atp which is
magnesium so you can get a lot of
magnesium and potassium from having
large salads i notice on the days that i
don't have a big salad i'm a little more
tired now out of all the things you can
do
the most important thing is to get your
diet straightened down i didn't know
that
in the past and so i was trying to take
all these vitamins and do all these
different things on top of eating too
many carbs it never worked so you need
to get on keto and do intermittent
fasting as a priority number two you
want to work on your stress so you can
then sleep that's number two because
they are connected and then number three
many times there could be some
underlying residue from some post
infection
or you have this latent virus that is
coming out of remission in which case
you need to take more b1 d3
zinc and some of the other things that i
recommend all right if you have not seen
my video on melatonin very important
video
check it out right here